[Musique]
vous emmène aujourd'hui au pavillon des
cadeaux juste là en bord de seine à
paris on est pas mal regardé la presque
envie de se baigner sauf que c'est la
cei ne gagne pas on va les rencontrer et
google pour parler du google next up
c'est un nouveau job qui a été présenté
aux allures ces trucs intéressants c'est
comment google home avec un écran peut
faire des choses intéressantes à
regarder ce que j'ai récupéré ce matin
je monte rapidement plusieurs récupérer
vous enfin dans quelques jours moi si
vous voyez nikon des petits bonds ça je
ne montre pas je ne sors pas je veux pas
me balader avec soin dans paris on à pas
lents quelques jours on voit du bleu
très conceptuel ya plein de couleurs
regardez pas comme ça joli bleu google
laquelle good c'est très bon le google
ça se voit
[Musique]
ok google ou le lancement la dernière
vidéo de monsieur dreux je ne connais
pas ce type il est très bizarre sonico
ouais ça très bien c'est venu voir les
google pixels on le laissera ben alors
le net faible qui scelle je t'ai fait
très bientôt
[Musique]
oh
olemps produits il est là c'est ça c'est
le google nestor vous sert plein de
choses avec
c'est un produit qui est vraiment très
intéressant que nous a vraiment montré
les cas d'usagés ce qu'on peut faire
avec tout ce que vous pouvez faire avec
un google assistant vous pouvez faire
avec le hub et ce qui est vraiment bien
c'est car pas mal de choses qui sont
développés pour un côté un peu plus
visuel vous avez bien évidemment une vue
complète de ce qu'on pouvait faire dans
votre maison à savoir monter les
ampoules laisser la lumière allumée la
bouilloire voir plein de choses suivent
des recettes ça c'est cool
lire des histoires à vos enfants vous
gérez le chauffage voir qui va sonner à
votre porte enfin il ya beaucoup de cas
d'usagé sont très intéressants avec
cette petite bête alors on va se tester
très très prochainement donc vous pouvez
dès maintenant vous abonner comme ça
vous saurez tout cela prendre en main
tranquillement dans quelques jours on va
parler aussi du google pixels 3 à
ixelles que j'ai récupéré en train de
tester donc je vous en parle aussi d'ici
quelques jours
ça c'est cool parce que je trouve ça
atteint sort il ya des choses sont un
peu pas forcément hyper fan ce que je
trouve qu'il est dommage là dessus c'est
déjà n'y a pas de caméra à l'avant donc
si vous voulez pouvoir communiquer avec
quelqu'un faire de la visio compte
quelque chose comme ça c'est pas
possible par contre c'est un petit outil
qu'est très bien et surtout il a le gros
avantage d'être assez compact petit
prend pas trop de place il ya un bon
volume sonore
ça c'est plutôt cool comme enjeu non par
goût par la voix merci beaucoup c'est
gentil tourné dans un bateau soit c'est
trop cool il ya ça va bouger ça va être
cool voilà maintenant quatre jours
mauvaise idée de contre jour là on est
calé dans un petit bateau tranquillement
pour parler justement du up ça c'est
vraiment cool entrailles je sors mes
notes j'ai plein de choses à vous dire
j'étais plein plein de trucs cool moi je
pense d'ailleurs que le produit
intéressant ça va dans le bon sens il
voulait faire on est dans le continuité
dans la suite logique de ce qu'on peut
faire avec le google assistant google
google au mini en fonction du format
vous vous laissez vous donc ça c'est
vraiment cool se permet de rajouter un
écran là où pouvaient être frustré avec
le google home de se dire hey mec juste
l'écran pour la partie visuelle des
choses qu'on pouvait faire un suivi des
recettes mais typiquement pouvoir voir
avoir ce côté visuel ça manquait et je
sens que ça va encore plus se développer
dans les temps à venir alors déjà le le
hardware moi je trouve vraiment très
intéressant vous avez un écran de 7
pouces résolution de 1200 par six ans on
n'est pas sûr d fhd plus on n'est pas
sûr du fhd on n'est pas sûr du âge d or
et se reformer un peu bâtard mais qui va
très bien avec l'appareil tel qu'il est
là vous avez
deux micros à l'avant deux micros longue
portée que pouvoir capter votre voix au
loin donc ça c'est plutôt cool vous avez
un gros parleur qui se situe au dos et
ce qui est bien c'est que les micros
pouvez venir les désactiver qu'un petit
bouton physique donc ça c'est plutôt
cool ça peut rassurer tous ceux qui se
poseraient des questions en termes de
vie privée ne pas être tout le temps
écouter vous avez aussi des petits
boutons sur le côté pour me régler le
volume il ya quand même beaucoup de son
ca c ça marche bien il ya un vrai savoir
faire face ondes de la part de google
là-dessus déjà sur google au mieux aux
mini le son est cool marche bien ce une
source mono ici pas d'eau parleurs
stéréo mais dans l'absolu c'est parce
qu'on vient chercher vous avez à l'avant
un capteur rgb qui veut dire d'adapter
l'affichage sans votre écran pour vous
ou quelque chose qui soit vraiment bien
en terme d'expérience surtout adapté à
la lumière de votre pièce et vous pouvez
bien évidemment piloter toutes vos
applications google que ce soit google
maps gmail compagnie et tutti quanti
donc ça c'est cool
alors on voit tout ce qu'on peut faire
avec dans la cuisine vous aller piloter
votre boule noire
vous allez pouvoir avoir vos recettes
donc pas forcément vous salir les mains
par contre ce cas ça c'est surprenant
ces cas pas de certification ip sur
cette machine donc pas résistant aux
éclaboussures potentiel alors je suis
persuadé que s'il ya une petite un petit
peu d'eau quelque chose qui va dessus la
machine va pas craindre mais c'est vrai
que sur une machine à peu près tout
terrain mais qui en tout cas une place
prédominante dans votre cuisine ça
aurait pu avoir un vrai sens qu' une
certification ip derrière après la
classification ip sont pas gratuites je
crois que c'est de l'ordre de 20 euros à
peu près par appareil dont kout est pour
ça qu'ils sont pas les de sucre
allez savoir vous avez dessus du
bluetooth 5.0 et vous avez interface qui
est sympa s'appelle l'interface homme
view sur lequel vous allez voir un peu
en gros récap de tous vos appareils
connectés la sonnette ou les ampoules
connectez vous à une petite interface
vous pilotez vous en faites ce que vous
voulez ça c'est assez cool c'est une
machine qui va être dispo dès mardi
prochain mardi 28 ça dépend de quel
moment vous allez regarder cette vidéo
au tarif de 129 euros il ya deux
couleurs un peu comme sur les google
phone vous avez une couleur grise et une
couleur charbon qui se rapproche plus du
noir dont qui ont aussi très sympa
pouvez bien évidemment qui était votre
musique spotify deezer youtube musique
et j'en passe et bien d'autres pouvez
poser toutes vos questions en plus et
même maille canal et dispos dessus si
vous regardez un petit bout de film
quand vous êtes en train de cuisiner ou
faire autre chose ça c'est complètement
possible vous avez les recettes avec
marmitons avec 750 grammes vous avez
cuisine actuelle offrir
beaucoup de choses pouvaient raconter
des histoires à vos enfants pour les
endormir vous pouvez régler le chauffage
enfin il ya beaucoup de cas d'usagé on
voit qui est très intéressant avec cette
machine c'est qu'elle vient se placer au
centre de votre vie connectée dans votre
intérieur
c'est elle qui prend le relais suis
vraiment un peu familial pour que tous
les membres de la famille puisse
communiquer et qu'ils puissent
communiquer avec tous vos appareils par
exemple mettez ça dans votre salon dans
votre cuisine vous mettez des google
hominick dans chaque pièce voulu passer
un message dit bah tiens passer un
message à tout le monde dans la maison
et tout le monde aura votre message
bastien venait à table ça évite de
hurler ça peut avoir un sens tout ça
c'est rigolo en tout cas est un autre
point qui est sympa c'est si vous avez
une petite sonnette qui est compatible
vous voyez qui sonne
vous pouvez ouvrir la porte à distance
il ya pas mal de cadres jusqu'à ce qu'on
voit est ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est la volonté de google est toujours
plus au centre de votre maison
d'apporter des solutions pratiques
rapides intéressante et ça c'est plutôt
cool parce que vous en pensez je la vide
a marqué tout ça en bas en commentaire
maintenant on va essayer un petit tour
de bateau histoire profiter le premier
qui tombent dans l'eau a perdu à
l'évasion vivre l'aventuré où ça glisse
mais non même pas peur laissez moi me
noyais allait pas polluer si je tombe
tout va bien waouh
mais ce n'est pas le pied marin c'est
moi qui conduis
c'est le chef qui pilote
[Musique]
e
merci beaucoup en tout cas ouais merci
capitaine est sympa pour venir faire du
bateau chez toi marins d'eau douce
ok cool c'est noté bon voila c'était
très sympa joli petit tour en bateau
très cool alors 38,9 trouve intéressant
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mark
et moi tout ça en bas commentaires dites
moi si c'est un produit qui peut vous
tenter et puis surtout abonnez-vous
parce qu'on en parle dans quelques jours
voilà vous fait des bisous bout à
bientôt tiens